[Music]
thank you
welcome to the data science hangout hope
everybody's having a great week I'm
Rachel if we haven't met yet let us know
if it's your first time joining in the
chat so we can all welcome you in
this is our open space to chat about
data Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data across
different Industries
every week we feature a different data
science leader as my co-host here to
help lead our discussion and answer
questions from you all
together we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for
everybody so we love to hear from
everyone no matter your level of
experience or background or area of work
it is totally okay to just listen in
there's always three ways you can ask
questions to and also provide your own
perspective
the one you can always jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom
two you could put questions into the
zoom chat I know you've all heard me say
this a lot of times now but feel free to
put a little star next to
your question in the zoom chat if you
wanted me to read it out loud if you're
in a coffee shop or something
or if your dog's barking but we also
have a slido link where you can ask
questions anonymously and I think our
team just shared that in the chat right
now we'll re-share it after for people
who have joined after the first few
minutes too
we do share the recordings of each
session up to the posit YouTube so you
can always go back and re-watch or share
with a friend or co-worker
if you hear anything loud in the
background there's some snow falling off
this side of the building right now
hopefully you won't won't hear that too
much but thank you so much Dara for
joining us as the co-host today Dara is
a data science manager at stripe and I'd
love to have you introduce yourself
maybe share a little bit about your role
and also something you like to do
outside of work sure sure so
um thank you for the intro my name is
Dara I as Rachel said I'm a data science
manager at stripe currently I've been at
stripe for about five years now my
current role is leading a team around
finance and operations data science so
we are very into forecasting we do a lot
of work on hierarchical forecasting
Financial forecasting at stripe spend a
lot of effort there we think a lot about
metrics and overall company metrics and
analytics and how we can understand our
business performance and then we work in
the operations space as well so we are
working on some various machine learning
projects there as well as capacity
planning and forecasting on that side
too so happy to talk about you know any
of that work in more detail
let's see one thing I like to do outside
of work
um I used to be kind of a Endurance
Sports person you know long distance
triathlons and running but I now have a
15 month old daughter who keeps me
pretty busy and spends most of my time
just parenting
well thank you so much for joining us
as we kind of wait for questions to come
in from everybody in the audience here
I'm curious if you could kind of give us
a little insight into some of the
problems that your team is trying to
help solve or things that you're working
on so you can put us in your your frame
of reference
cool so yeah let me talk about a couple
of things so
um at stripe we're interested in
forecasting as many businesses are in
understanding how much payment volume
are we going to have next year how many
active users will we have what will our
uptime be there's a number of
forecasting problems that come uh that
come into play that you know are a
business Advantage if we are good at
them we can set the budget we can set
our targets we can direct our efforts
appropriately and so my team is spends a
lot of time thinking about how we can
produce the best forecast for stripe I
really as a side note I like forecasting
as a data science area because it's not
one that you always you know learn about
in a machine learning course or spend a
lot of time thinking about in your you
know more formal education I didn't at
least but now in you know sort of on the
business side it's an extremely
practical uh business problem to be able
to solve at the same time it's very
interesting statistically and there's a
lot of work that we do
um to you know sort of experiment and
find the best methods for doing
forecasting so we do what's called
hierarchical forecasting so this means
that we want to have a forecast for
stripe overall we want to know you know
what's our total payment volume going to
be for the whole company but we also
want to know what is it going to be for
each region what is it going to be for
each business type what's it going to be
for each cohort there's all these
Dimensions that flow down so you can
kind of think of this as a hierarchy
right where all of the dimensions then
need to add up to the total right we
have to have a coherent hierarchy is how
we talk about it and so we use this
method where we can actually choose any
forecasting method we want for each node
of the hierarchy you know we use a lot
of classical forecasting methods like
arima and exponential smoothing we also
experiment with other types of methods
and we use those to make estimates and
then we apply sort of a meta model on
top of it hierarchical reconciliation to
basically tweak each forecast as little
as possible so that they all still add
up to the total forecast and that then
you know we apply some additional
adjustments on top of that and that
become the budget for the company
thank you I see Mark had a follow-up
question on that Mark do you want to
jump in and ask that
yeah sure let me turn my video
um you know I I'm asking
um just curious about your
um and you kind of went into a little
bit of the detail there but uh I'm
curious about if you're able to expand
on the
Target setting methodology and if you
dip into any I guess like non-financial
um targets and like I guess different
level setting
um I'm actually literally have it open
right now working on our like next
fiscal years
um
targets for the hospital system I work
for
um so yeah just really curious to get
like your perspective on some of the
non-financial
um metrics that you guys keep track of
and if and how you do
yeah we do we're actually building a
platform to do General hierarchical
forecasting for any metric at stripe so
we've expanded this we do some sales
planning right now which is a little bit
Financial
um we do it for our active users and
we're using looking at things like uh
like uptime as well like how how much um
should we expect you know stripe to be
live and yeah so the we generally find
that the approaches oh and we also do a
lot in Ops too so capacity planning for
our support volume support tickets
um we found that the methods are pretty
similar across you know all of these
different types of problems there's a
lot of nuance in terms of uh making sure
that you capture the data correctly and
capture actually solve the business
problem right you can just sort of throw
General forecasting Methods at something
but
um but we have found in general that the
the hierarchical format works really
well in a business setting in that you
know you often care about some more
detailed dimensions and then you also
care about adding up to the hole
awesome thank you
Crystal I see you asked a question in
the chat too do you want to jump in
and maybe I miss I can ask that that one
too and if you want to add any context
feel free but the question was any
exploration of chat GPT to see uh to
identify any possible or meaningful use
it's funny you ask um yes we are playing
with it um we actually were playing with
it before it was cool I have to say so
back when it was just gpt3 before
um some of the hype this fall uh we are
experimenting with it in our support
flow so to be able to help agents answer
questions
um more accurately and much more quickly
for our users so we are still early days
but we're pretty enthusiastic we've done
a lot of NLP work generally on the op
side so we classify our issues using
Bert which is sort of a previous
generation natural language processing
model and you know that allows us to
know what kind of questions are getting
asked and what topics our support issues
are about which we then use to direct a
lot of internal efforts like where
should we be you know making updates or
bug fixes in our product based on what
the support tickets are about
thank you I want to make sure I get over
to some of the anonymous questions too
and just remind people if you want to
use slido you can use that link in the
chat but somebody had asked earlier I
would love to learn Dara how you have
found the transition from computational
Immunology to finance and operations
yeah yeah I'll try to try to not blather
on for too long about this um you know
everyone a lot of data scientists have
interesting or unusual career paths um
I'm no exception here so I was I did my
PhD in computational Immunology
um it actually started out as a PhD in
pure Immunology so I was a wet lab
biologist you know pipetting and doing
experiments I realized you know pretty
quickly in my PhD I took an R class and
a python class and then I took you know
more CS courses and I took more
statistics and machine learning and you
know realized pretty quickly that that
was a direction that would enable me to
be a better biologist and also just an
area of a lot of interest for me
um you know I was lucky enough to be
able to do a ton of coursework and
really direct my research that direction
so by the time I finished my PhD I was
doing fully computational work when I
finished up I thought what do I want to
do next I
I really enjoyed Academia had a great
time there thought very seriously about
academic post-docs and then also thought
you know I really like this data side of
what I've been doing I really like the
statistics and the ML and all the
programming that I've been doing and so
I looked at data science positions as
well so I applied to both um and in the
end I uh decided to take a data science
position because I felt like it was much
more different than what I had done
before and that I would learn more in
that position just because
um it would really force me to continue
to build the skills that I had started
to develop in my PhD and put me into an
you know entirely new problem space that
I hadn't been before
so that's what I did I went first to a
small health insurance startup called
Collective health I was there for two
years a great thing about going to a
startup is you learn a lot of data
engineering and so I you know spent a
lot of time building pipelines and
really getting to know uh you know sort
of bolstering how you actually write
code in a environment with other people
right in your PhD it's very much just
sort of you and your notebook and this
was now actually having to write in a
more production environment so learned a
lot there and I did health insurance
thinking that it would be somewhat
related to my PhD work which was on HIV
and the immune system turns out not
really that much that much uh overlap
between those two subject areas but I
really loved the data science side of
things and I really loved having impact
in business and being able to see the
results of my work more directly so
after a couple years I decided to move
over to stripe
um stripe was very appealing because it
was
um
it was still it was big enough to have
invested in data infrastructure there
was a ton of data available
um you know I was going to be able to do
more statistical and ml type work but it
was still small enough that there were a
lot of unsolved problems which is
actually you know five years later still
true with stripe today
um and so that's what made me you know
decide to that I you know was more
interested in the data problems rather
than focused on a particular domain it
has turned out that Financial payments
are a complex system just like the
immune system is a complex system so
even though I do not use my domain
knowledge for my PhD that much I still
use a lot of the skills that I learned I
still use you know a lot of the how to
present how to do research how to think
about problems how to break down complex
problems
um all the time and so you know really
have found that if you think about it
the right way you know skills are pretty
transferable
absolutely
um I'm starting to see a bunch of other
questions coming into and uh Alan I saw
you at ass one earlier do you want to
jump in
sure hi there
um I'm I'm really interested in the in
part of the forecasting where if you
have to reconcile like SME input from
people who like historically would have
been setting targets like sales people
and their leaders and I don't know what
the organization is how it just sort of
maps to that but what's what's the
process of sort of buying from them that
the forecasting you're doing seems like
a realistic enough picture of the world
that they buy it and that they'll go
sort of you know work along it
um or if their input gets Incorporated
earlier in the process somewhere so
they're brought along kind of from the
beginning in a way just curious how that
kind of gets negotiated out
um yeah in the organization super
interesting question yeah and it's
um it's ongoing sort of evolution for
how we do this interaction because it's
um it's very important to get the input
from stakeholders right there might be a
big sales deal coming down the pipeline
that no statistical model will know
about right there might be some big
product launch plans that
um you know that we're just not going to
be able to learn from history and so
um we find that interaction very
important when we started doing this too
when we started doing the you know we
call it the statistical forecasting and
the adjustments you know it was all done
in spreadsheets by Finance folks and we
did really have to prove our value of
you know how does a statistical model
actually help
um so our current system is we have you
know the statistical model we actually
do you know that's all done by data
science we do back testing and reports
to be able to you know build confidence
in each level of the hierarchy so that
people can understand where do they
expect accuracy where do they expect
less accuracy and then we have a whole
process with the finance and strategy
team where they make adjustment to the
forecast and you know are pretty clear
about where they are doing adjustments
and how how it's affecting the total and
then we track both the statistical
versus the adjusted forecast and what
we've learned over time is that making
adjustments in certain ways or certain
places is very important and very
effective and we have sort of encouraged
the finance strategy team to focus their
efforts there whereas you know in other
places the statistical model is quite
accurate and it's best
to spend effort elsewhere so that's
that's the Baseline of how we think
about it you know again ever evolving
but also we also have an embedded model
right so we sit with finance and
strategy we work really closely with
them
we really understand their problems it's
very much a like partnership type model
rather than a you know throw a model
over the wall type model right
yeah it does it's really um and it
sounds like for having been sort of
driving it for us relatively small
handful of years it sounds really mature
and really
um like uh comprehensive in a in a bunch
of ways that I think are really
impressive so yeah that's cool thank you
we still have a lot more that we would
like to do for sure yeah there's all the
literature about adjustments and the
best way to do them and we applied some
of those things but there's so much more
that I think we could do to really
maximize our effort yeah thank you
I know you just said you sit with the
finance and strategy team so I was
curious
is there like a general data science
team for the whole company or is there
data science team like Pockets within
each group yep so General data science
team and I'm using sit with to be clear
I'm using sit with someone here we used
to sit with them when we were fully in
office and now it's
you know sit with them on Zoom but
um centralized data science team so we
have a hybrid embedded model so every
data scientist has a partner team that
they work really closely with right so
I'm on the business side with the
finance and operations teams others
might work with product or engineering
teams
um and we really you know act like
members of that team get to know their
problems get to under you know attend
their meetings their offsides understand
what's going on with them and do joint
planning together and so we like to
think it's you know Best of Both Worlds
making sure we are solving real business
problems but the centralized data
science team Keeps Us pushing the
envelope uh technologically and
innovatively as well
yeah that's really cool
uh deep shy I see you had a question
over on slido do you want to ask that
year
sure I um video because Alan's question
was slightly similar but I'll ask a
slightly different way so you do get
like financed and stakeholder buy-in but
sometimes if you when you just recently
have started statistical Finance models
what happens if it deflates what the
previous Finance predictions were and
have you had such a scenario because
those Vines are like so difficult and it
has set scenarios as well so how do you
get a buy-in there yeah
um it's a great question as much as you
can bring in confidence intervals or
back testing you know statistics and
show here's what we expect
um you know those of course are only as
good as your input data and that can be
challenging when you're first starting
out but that is you know Finance folks
are very quantitative right they're very
data oriented they want to know how at
least you know our finance folks are
um so that helps uh there's you know in
our experience it did take some time
just to build trust and so it was making
sure that we had all the very detailed
tracking in place and so it wasn't
saying hey we're gonna replace your
model it was saying let's run them in
parallel right and let's just sort of
track you know the statistical model the
finance model maybe some combination of
them if we want to do an adjusted model
and let's you know look for six months
at how those go and see
um you know let's just sort of be
objective about it if we can and that
that ultimately was you know very
helpful for us in building some trust
and confidence but it is it is you know
a relationship that just it does take
some time to build
definitely thanks Tara
thank you all for all the great
questions too I see
um one on slido was with your
forecasting how do you share results to
those who make decisions is it through
Excel PowerPoint do you ever use shiny
or SharePoint power bi
ah I would love it if we had shiny we
don't have it set up steadilated Stripes
so we have our own internal rolled um
forecasting sorry not forecasting
dashboarding tool that is uh SQL based
and allows us to
um sort of build uh pretty nice
dashboards that way on our data so we
use a lot of that
um we will you know some we will
sometimes you know make sort of bespoke
plots in r or Python and share those we
do a lot of PowerPoint or you know
Google Slides presentations as well
um
and sometimes we you know when we're
working directly with FNS there
certainly are sort of queries and
spreadsheets and you know that's we try
to speak their language where we can so
well we might operate in more of a SQL
land they might be operating more of a
spreadsheet land and so we try to
interface between those things
great thank you
um Abigail I love your question into the
in the chat I know we get to hear a lot
of different perspectives on this this
one and love to have you ask that here
oh I don't know if we can hear you yet
so I can ask it and feel free to jump in
after if you want but the question was
how do you feel about being a manager
versus being in a purely SME individual
contributor role do you still get to
code
um these days not as much when I so I
started as an icy at stripe and
um I transitioned about a year into my
tenure and when I first transitioned you
know managing a small team I still did
about 50 coding
um and now I you know manage usually
between eight to ten folks so I do you
know more peer management stuff
um I think you know I've really enjoyed
the transition I find that I think you
know the key question to ask yourself if
you're thinking about IC versus
management is how motivated you will be
by enabling other folks to do work
versus
um how many how motivated are you by you
know solving problems and shipping work
uh yourself and most people would be you
know motivated by both of those things
but it's really sort of trying to figure
out for yourself where you want to
prioritize spending your time and how
helpful
um you know each of those roles might be
to you in achieving that goal
that's my short answer I'm happy happy
to go in more these are great questions
thank you
and Eugene AC you had a question in the
chat do you want to jump in next
sure it's uh
um
my question is just about the
sophistication of modeling so you you
seem to discuss quite a few rather
sophisticated models in your forecasting
uh as you gave the your short sort of
summary of what you're using and I'm
just curious has the increase in I
assume you started simple right so has
the increase in sophistication
actually significantly changed uh your
results or your outcomes uh as you've
you know as the the models have evolved
yeah this is um
this is a good question so
our forecast
the hierarchical reconciliation is very
important and um you know that has
certainly increased in sophistication
over time the underlying models
themselves we actually don't use
anything most of the time
um they're not super fancy forecasting
models we're not doing
um you know some of the things that are
winning the M5 forecasting competition
these days it's you know sort of bread
and butter
um arima and exponential smoothing for
the most part we you know we'll we'll
play with other models too and we have
found that for our particular business
problem that works really well because
we have a decent amount of History we
have you know very important to capture
seasonality we're doing monthly
forecasts so uh if we are able to
capture what we need to capture for
those models um so the choice of
um the choice of forecasting model is so
dependent on the problem that you have
and the
um
you know there's so many things to
consider about your input data I think
if we had
um you know a lot of external regressors
that we were trying to Model A lot of
sort of parallel processes happening
um you know then probably different
kinds of models potentially more of the
deep learning forecasting models that
have come into play recently uh might be
really helpful to us as well but you
know for the most part
um you know a lot of a lot of bread and
butter forecasting models work well for
us
thank you and Trevor I know you had a
somewhat similar question so I just
wanted to see if that addressed your
question too or if you want to add on to
that yeah hi Richard hi Trevor
it is indeed a connected question you
know because
they so most forecasts and models look
at historical data
to predict the future right so that is
assuming that the past is the future
right and of course we understand that
can change right so for example when
kovid came along it disrupted many
models right nobody could have
forecasted that kovid would have had the
effect that it had on businesses right
so I'm just wondering
um to what extent Dara there are
factors that would not have been been in
your models that would have affected
maybe the accuracy of your models that's
one and two
we use historical data to make
predictions at the end of the day
let's say let's say your forecast in
sales right and you don't forecasted it
to be a certain amount right based on
historical data but then when reality
happens at the end of a period you get
the actual numbers so I want to know two
things really
how close are you typically to your
forecast and how do you manage
factors that weren't considered in the
model in the first place
because of you know you're in thinking
about those um I hope I'm clear yeah
sort of some fundamental problems
problems of forecasting in a business
setting yeah we do include external
regressors and
um now of course like we didn't we
didn't predict covid when I look back
now like forecasting was so easy
pre-covered and now post coveted it's
you know a whole different ball game um
so now you know we do include requesters
that try to sort of
um account for the past covet changes in
our data um what we don't want is to you
know continue forecasting more covids in
the future
um so we do have some sort of external
things that we use that help us to
predict that we also do factor in
macroeconomic variables on top of our
statistical forecast that you know again
you still have to make your own
predictions and sort of decide as a
company what you think might happen we
do sometimes do scenario based planning
as well you know Baseline and here's
sort of The Upside or the downside
scenario to try to give the business
some framework for how to think about
possibilities
um accuracy and you know how what do we
do when the forecast is off so with the
hierarchical forecast you know the
general pattern is that we are not that
accurate at the lowest levels of the
hierarchy generally you know for
forecasting
um one cohort one region one business
type that gets to be a pretty small set
of data we don't have as much history
um or there may be erratic patterns in
it and so we don't have as much accuracy
down there but then when you add up to
the total you know you have a much more
robust data set and we tend to be more
accurate at the higher levels of the
forecast we do a lot of tracking we
create a lot of dashboards we try to be
really clear with you know where we're
doing well and where we're not we do we
forecast throughout the year to be able
to
sort of update our best guess on where
we think we're going to land given more
data has come in throughout the year
um so that is helpful and then we just
sit side by side with finance and
strategy and do the analysis and try to
understand you know when the forecast
was off what are the segments in which
it was off can we identify the root
cause for that and how can we improve
our forecast model for the next
iteration so no no magic bullet
certainly but you know a lot of
continual efforts to you know try to
improve over time
thank you
thank you very much
and I went to say this earlier too I
know that I get to know everybody when I
see people every week but when you ask
your question feel free to introduce
yourself again I know maybe we haven't
done introductions in a long time too
so feel free to throw that in there as
well if you want to don't have to
um but Nico I saw you had asked a
question in the chat a bit earlier do
you want to ask that one next
yeah sure thank you very much so I'm
going with the introduction first I'm I
work
um in a small data science team JP
Morgan
um I was interested you mentioned Dara
thank you so much for being here
um you talked about that you did before
some kind of
um analysis on tickets on incidents I
would like to know if you can mention
some kind of the maybe key metrics that
you track and if so if you also do some
kind of statistical process control to
those
you said support tickets that's what
you're asking about
yep um yeah so we do we do the
forecasting for the support tickets and
we also do some ml modeling uh around
improving our support processes so I
talked about our issue classification
model you know we're working with gbt
now too
um you know some of the things we track
a total number of tickets how long does
it take to solve a ticket on average
um you know what is our our overall like
how many tickets do we get to within SLA
whatever we set that at
um we are very focused on user
experience so we track csat you know
customer csat and what's uh what are we
hearing from users in terms of their
um
their overall satisfaction you know we
look a lot to it
um which tickets you know buy some
metrics that we have which tickets do we
think we did really great on user
experience and which ones do we think we
did really terribly and you know try to
sort of expand the first bucket and
shrink the second one
um so there's a lot more to do but those
are some of the some of the things that
we think about
um we don't exactly do process controls
we do help with capacity planning um so
with our forecast we feed into how much
vendor uh
sort of capacity we need to order we
have you know Global Network of vendors
that answer our support tickets
um so we we work with them too but I
think there's actually a lot more room
for even more data science work there
awesome thanks
thank you
um Adrian I I think you had a question a
little bit earlier we didn't get to yet
too do you want to jump in next
yeah hey thanks
um
I'm an analytics manager here at Wayfair
I um I asked a question earlier and it
might be a little bit
untimely now but I'll go back um we were
talking about the forecasting and
specifically you're talking about how
you integrated
or are you allowed it to be influenced
by the smes near the end of the process
and I'm curious or actually I straight
up adjusted my smbs at the end of the
process
um
I'm curious how much front loading that
SME adjustment might take place like
Financial growth projections or
um
marketing uh budgets things like this
how much of that actually takes place at
the beginning and how much of that
initial forecasting is really just if
the past repeats itself here's what
would happen and if there's not a
perfect answer because you said there is
a data science to sort of
does that piece maybe do you have a
favorite infrastructure or framework or
resource to see how these get navigated
so the question is about you know you
know how much does sort of the finance
team make their own projections that
um they might add to our forecast versus
how much is it sort of after the fact
once the forecast is in place yeah yeah
exactly I've seen I've seen both of
these sort of cases happen where Finance
has a 33 growth and that's where we're
going so you really better track on that
because they're it's sort of a
self-fulfilling prophecy but I've also
seen it where we started the vacuum and
I'm curious what your experience has
been I'm curious that there's a best way
yeah so I think our approach is
typically
into segments
there are you know alluded to this
earlier there are places where the
statistical models do really well right
we have enough history there is not a
lot of sort of external factors that
influence that it's sort of uh
continuous time series that we can
forecast pretty well
um and so we sort of explain that to the
financing strategy team and work with
them and you know show them the
statistics on it
um and then we find that there are other
places where that kind of financial
modeling is very fruitful and it's very
helpful to
um adjusting the forecast right where
there are things that the statistical
model will do less well or might not
know about or
um you know really could use some
adjustment and that's how
um in those places you know we really
um open it up and encourage adjustments
I actually think we could have even more
process control we're just talking about
controls around this and you know around
How We Do The Adjustment process that's
something I'd like us to you know
continue to work on
um
but that's generally how it works so the
finance team does do some modeling and
does have their sort of priors if you
will that they're adjusting the forecast
by but we you know we work together to
make sure that they are spending their
effort in the right ways when they do
those adjustments
thank you you I'm sorry I didn't notice
your hand on Zoom before do you want to
jump in
sure uh hi there uh Yoko here so first
uh thank you for your time and thank you
for all the insights you shared uh
similar background here I'm a data
science professional I'm working a
finance company and before that you'll
work in computational immunology and for
me I want to email chemistry so I'm a
similar password here so I have one
question so because we both know that
for forecasting models in the finance
field one of the challenges is to
incorporate microeconomic factors such
as GDP unemployment rate inflation all
these capsues so I'm wondering for all
the forecasting models you mentioned do
you do either of them using
microeconomic variables and if if it
does what do you think is the best
practice to incorporate such variables
yep yep good question
um Yep this is very important to us and
you know with um 2022 for example became
even more important for us to understand
the effect of the macro economy on our
forecast
um so we do we currently have this as
sort of a second layer of modeling
um that's uh you know sort of an overlay
that we put on our statistical model
where we say you know we do our best to
learn as much as we can from the past
about how the you know things like GDP
might affect our forecast and apply
those as a secondary model to our model
um one thing that's worked really well
is having scenarios here right because
uh you know we we can make our best
predictions but in the end it's still
predictions with these macroeconomic
factors right it's not as if
incorporating them magically makes your
forecast work you still have to decide
what the future is going to look like
and so having
um you know different scenarios sort of
high medium low or however we've set it
up different ways different Cycles to
give the business some indication of you
know we we can't predict the future
either we don't know what's going to
happen with the macro economy but
um this at least allows them to say okay
if you know if um something goes well
here's what we might expect to happen if
we you know want to plan to a sort of
worst case scenario here's how we might
do that and you can imagine in you know
different sort of business decision
making scenarios they might want to use
different ones
thank you
thank you and Marlene I see your hands
raised too
crazy
um so um hi long time caller first time
listening no I'm just kidding Dara
thanks for presenting this morning
um sorry the coffee's just kicked in
gang so I'm all over the place
um you know I I've shared on numerous
calls before that I'm just kind of an
army of one in my company we don't have
a formal data science team we're far
from the machine learning you know kind
of area of tech and
um right now my focus is just building a
culture that understands that there's a
need for data science and giving some
practical uses for Automation and
um better analytics so my question to
you is it's more around mentorship I
wanted to know if you guys had any kind
of
culture that promotes say mentorship do
you say
um have a senior data scientist that
takes a junior under their wing or even
like a fledgling data scientist right
just somebody who's got some great
analytic prowess that somehow gets built
coming into the fold I mean I don't know
take that question where you want to go
but it's around mentorship essentially
thanks Sarah totally yeah thank you for
asking we do have a mentorship program
so we have uh
there is one within data science our
team is
what are we around 170 180 uh folks
right now so we've gotten big enough
that we you know do have sort of a
spectrum of more Junior to more senior
data scientists we do pair them up and
allow them to um to you know exchange uh
knowledge and mentorship more formally
we have uh some years we have an intern
program as well where we've
um taken in you know folks who are sort
of finishing up some level of schooling
and had them as you know summer interns
um on data science
um you know a lot of them have converted
them to full-time data scientists and
that has worked out really well for us
we also have a very strong learning
culture on our data science team and so
we
um you know part of having a centralized
data science team brings this benefit so
we do a lot of lunch and learns
um where you know teach each other about
our current work we have a learning
group where we you know we'll read a
blog post or you know at some points
we've actually gone through a whole
Coursera course together or you know
depending on the interests of the group
will sort of get work together on those
um and then we have you know various
sort of targeted seminars at stripe two
as well so there's the ml seminar
there's a more General Tech seminar
sometimes we'll bring in external
speakers as well so I think that can be
you know that's probably not unique to
stripe I think that's something that
data science brings to a company really
well is most data scientists are
motivated by continual learning
continuing to expand your skills getting
to try out new methods getting to
um you know just continue to both add
both depth and breadth to your technical
skill set um so uh yeah I found that to
be you know a really positive part of
working as part of a data science team
and I see Adrian had a follow-up there
on on which Coursera course did the team
do together
uh we this was like two three years ago
we did the learning course at the time
there was just I think one General deep
learning course probably has expanded
now
nice and kind of I guess follow-up
question to Marlene's it too I was
poking around on LinkedIn and saw a few
roles at stripe and I noticed that one
of them mentioned like helping to build
the data science Community there and so
aside from like some of the learning and
getting together to learn together are
there other ways that people highlight
their work like internal meetup groups
or things like that or slack or teams
channels yep we have um
uh so we have a very big like written
culture at stripe um and that includes
emails and so we said what we call
shipped emails company-wide so you
finish a project you're encouraged to
write it up and send it to uh if it's a
very big project you send it to the
whole company if it's sort of a
medium-sized project we might send it to
the data science team and our partner
teams but strong culture of shipping and
celebrating work that way as well as
making sure that your work has as much
impact as possible sometimes you know
sharing it with another team or another
person you know actually helps you find
another use case for something that
you've built so strong culture sharing
there
um we have you know various levels of
Team meetings as well so full data
science team meeting where we do sort of
lightning talks you know a few short
talks since that's a big group about
recent work and then we have sort of our
medium meeting where medium media
meeting like our our you know maybe 30
or 40 people
um more we you know give maybe a 15
minute presentation on more Polished
Work and then in my team meeting of 10
people we do very early stage technical
feedback and so for that one we require
that you do not prepare anything for it
and just you know put up your code put
up your doc put up your random notes on
something and talk through something
very early stage that you're thinking
about and we found that one in
particular to be really helpful to folks
this sort of low stakes
environment where you can bounce your
ideas off of each other especially
coping times that's been really helpful
to you know building some team
camaraderie and also I'm sharing good
feedback
um Alan I see you just put something in
the chat you want to jump in next
sure I've got I'm thinking of lots of
lots of questions today
um I'm curious how if you have a balance
that you can maintain between the sort
of routine things like Financial
forecasting that has an annual Cadence
or a quarterly requirement or whatever
with room to like experiment and learn
new methods
um try out tools shop those around into
the organization and how do you how do
you meet all those needed commitments
with how do you balance that with like
room to explore Room to Grow for your
team to make sure that they're um you
know uh able to try things out that may
not have a known Business Connection yet
but but you know
um you want to give them that that kind
of opportunity like is that something
you're able to do and if so uh how do
you do it
yeah a million dollar question
um so we do a few a few strategies here
um this also is you know something that
we continually work on and try to
promote
um we do uh planning each half with our
partners
um and so we aim to get you know when we
do this sort of biannual planning we aim
to get the most important projects to
them on our roadmap so that we can you
know jointly decide what those are and
that allows you know typically there
within those larger projects there's
some room for you know new methods or
innovation experimentation while still
working towards something that is key to
the business and that you know Partners
have decided is important to them and so
that works well for uh you know trying
to build in a bit more of that sort of
longer term project that you know allows
a data scientist to dig in on the
methodology side but then you know of
course we build flexibility into the
process too things come up you know
there may be or did things there are all
the time that come up that very
important as well well that you know
folks work on and so we you know just
sort of continually evaluate those and
we're you know I spend a ton of time
just having conversations about
resourcing and making trade-offs on what
the team is working on
um you know I see that as a key role of
a manager
we also do we have a good tradition of
quarterly career chats so I do quarterly
chats with everyone on my team talk
about their you know chance to zoom out
and talk longer term about their
interests and from there I find out
um you know what kind of projects are
they interested in that they're not
currently working on or are they things
they're working on that they're less
interested in there's of course you know
you have to find the business need right
we're not a research team we don't do
sort of um you know pure r d work but
often by just having a good grasp on
where people want to go and what they're
interested in you know when I hear about
new projects I'm able to help Target
those appropriately to folks
awesome thanks a lot of that sounds
familiar the stuff that I'm trying to do
better as well
yeah it's a continual process for sure
yeah
I was just making a note of the
quarterly career chats too and I was
just curious how like how do you frame
that with your direct reports like is
that an actual formal process that they
go through or just informal conversation
so the first time when I have a new
direct report either new to stripe or
new to reporting to me I asked them you
know it's fairly you know a more
structured chat we go through their
career history and ask a lot of
questions about the decisions that
they've made along their way and their
interests and you know what brought them
to stripe and you know a lot of sort of
just getting to understand their career
motivations for subsequent ones it is
more open a lot of folks you know have a
more structured idea of what they want
from their career and we might talk
through that plan each time I'll often
come with you know questions or new
Frameworks that I'm thinking about from
how to think about your career and bring
those you know some folks are either
earlier or more open or less sure about
their career and in that case you know I
might direct the conversation a little
bit more so it's fairly tailored to the
individual
thank you okay so I see two anonymous
questions that are kind of on the same
topic so let me combine them both here
but the questions are
around do you support both R and python
users on your team and what does that
split look like
um
actually let me ask that part first so I
don't there are too many questions that
one
we do we do we um we
used to do all of our forecasting are
actually in recently you know python has
stepped it up a bit and we've been doing
a lot more in Python part of the reason
for that is that stripe is somewhat more
python based in our infrastructure and
so doing it in Python allows us to
integrate with the rest of stripe
systems much more easily we do you know
support R here we have our notebooks we
have uh the ability to schedule jobs in
R but I'd say it's you know more like 20
to 30 percent of data science usage and
python is a little bit more which you
know R is close to my heart that's the
programming language that I've started
out in in grad school and um you know I
could live in the Tidy verse all day but
um you know we use it a bit more for
sort of analytical exploratory analysis
work I would say in Python a bit more
for you know in production jobs
in the the follow-up question there was
do you encourage and support folks who
want to learn one while being more
proficient in the other
certainly I just had someone on my team
who was more proficient in R but wanted
to learn more Python and we sort of
designed a project for her that allowed
her to do that
awesome
um another anonymous question from
earlier was um
based on
the fact that there would be underlying
uncertainties in the forecast how do you
make your partner teams aware of and
consider those uncertainties
uh yeah yeah a complex question
we talk about it a lot with them we show
the back testing results those are
usually helpful as sort of quantitative
you know mape doesn't tell you
everything but it tells you something
about you know when we looked over the
past year here's the amount of error
that we saw here's how you might think
about that going forward
um we there's a lot of you know sort of
fancier joint uncertainty throughout the
hierarchy methodologies that we are
exploring as well I think uncertainty is
one of the you know most useful concepts
for you know forecasting within the
business but it's very hard to uh to to
sort of propagate the red level of
uncertainty throughout the hierarchy
um you know because you introduce
uncertainty both of the modeling the
initial modeling you know various points
and in the reconciliation and so
um so that's you know somewhat somewhat
more of an interesting problem
um to get to uh uncertain to get to
uncertainty bands that you're actually
confident in
um so we do that you know we explored
from the strategical side but we also
from the business side just sort of take
the perspective of you know you should
um here's what we've seen historically
you know you should expect some
uncertainty in the forecast and then you
know really digging in when we do see
forecast misses
thank you
I saw on uh LinkedIn I think it was a
post maybe from a year ago where you're
presenting on like managing a remote and
globally distributed data science team
and was curious if you have any tips
that you'd like to share with us in
terms of managing a team that's that's
all over
yeah yeah and this was true even
pre-covers I have folks in Dublin
Ireland uh in New York DC I'm in
Minnesota folks in SF and Seattle I
think that's it so it's you know we're
very distributed have been for a while
um I talked a bit about the early stage
technical feedback meetings that has
actually been a surprisingly useful
thing to do for
um just for making sure that we have
that sort of weekly touch point with the
team
um you know you can do Zoom happy hours
and those kinds of things and those are
nice but it's nice to have a little bit
of structure and topic to you know what
we're trying to do and to be able to
have
um you know somewhat of a technical
conversation in a you know again very
low stakes environment we don't expect
you to have a polished presentation but
you know much more of a rainstorm type
atmosphere so having that touch Point
has been really nice
um what else do we do snacks people love
snacks so I will if uh there are a
number of services that you know you can
send snacks uh to people that just you
know I think there's a there's a certain
you know nice feeling that people get by
sharing the same snacks on Zoom it's a
good one
um
trying to remember what other what are
our other strategies I think just oh
focusing on onboarding that's another
big one um with you know when folks
start remotely that's a very different
experience then it used to be where they
were in the office you know among
everybody in a starting class seeing
everyone
um so I focus really closely on new
folks I meet with them every day when
they're starting I set up meetings with
the relevant people that they need to
meet I make sure they have the resources
that they need I focus you know the
first month or so just focus really
closely on new folks and making sure
they get integrated because it doesn't
happen naturally in a remote world you
really have to work at that
absolutely I love the point of like even
just sharing the same snacks like
something little like that and Libby I
see you timed your comment perfectly to
when Dara was actually talking about
onboarding too so just want to see if
you had any follow-up question on that
Libby
yeah that was really really well timed I
asked it and then start yesterday
um yeah I think onboarding is a a really
tough thing in data science in general
and then extra tough when everybody's
remote right and so I was kind of
wondering what you know emphasis you put
on that and how it worked and if you
buddied people up and
um things like that but you really hit
the nail on the head it has to be
intentional that's not gonna happen
spontaneously right people aren't going
to just integrate into a group and
seamlessly work with everybody there has
to be some intention there so that was
good to hear if you have any expansion
on that I'd love to hear but if not you
did a great job answering
yeah you hit most of the points we do
have spin-up buddies and so people get
paired up with an existing data
scientist or data analyst that um you
know they can meet with and ask any
question to at any point there's a
stripe wide sort of onboarding
curriculum that you know teaches people
about payments and the stripe product
and then we have a data science specific
curriculum as well you know how to set
up your environment how do we use git at
stripe you know some of the more
technical classes that we run
um and those are both pretty helpful um
but yeah from there it is very much just
like making sure to meet with the right
when we have a spin-up project so that's
the other thing that we do you know very
intentionally we plan a sort of uh
well-scoped project that we give to new
folks that should allow them some room
for exploration it should be important
to the business but not
um business critical need it next week
type of project so that they can you
know ship something that is important
but not feel that sort of time fresher
immediately they need to have some time
to you know spin up on our systems and
meet folks
that's great who comes up with that
project the manager does okay
and just do like the newly onboarded
people kind of like work together on
that and share results from each other
because there's enough Engineers on the
data science side it's typically just
sort of one person per project
cool
um so I know we're getting to the end of
our our time here but one question I I
love to ask people when we have time is
what is the best career advice that
you've ever received or maybe not best
but something that sticks into your mind
um sometimes things in my mind is to
think about choosing the Wild Card when
you're presented with multiple choices
um so you know for me when I was
choosing my PhD advisor I had two
rotation you do three rotations right I
had two rotations that
um I had planned ahead of time that I
knew I was very interested in their
research that would go really well
um you know I thought and they did both
go really well and I really like those
labs and then the third one was
um you know this brand new professor I
would be the first grad student it was a
little bit outside the kind of research
that I had done before so I thought you
know I'll just
um do this wild card rotation and of
course you know that was the lab that I
ended up joining I was the first grad
student and ended up having just this
fantastic experience with my advisor and
with the research and that also you know
has held true as I've made other career
decisions along the way you know
choosing to go to stripe rather than
stay in something in biology choosing to
go to data science rather than do an
academic postdoc
um you know sometimes that wild card
choices can feel a little scary but also
kind of enticing and
um yeah for me just trying to not be
afraid to choose that option among
choices worked out well
thank you that's great advice
and Priyanka I like your comment in the
chat to when I asked that question to
also frame it as it could be an ice type
you've been given or that you have given
somebody else to
I just wanted to double check that I
haven't missed anybody's questions in
the chat or on slido so feel free to
raise your hand here or just unmute as
well
I'll give people a few seconds here
um but but Dara when you were talking
about some of the conversations with you
you have with your direct reports on
their career growth you mentioned some
like recommended reading or resources
that you give them and was curious if
that's something you could share with us
or if you have any books that you'd
recommend
um sure so I mean so we are
at stripe there's often you know manager
workshops or trainings and so I'm you
know constantly in a state of learning
as well about uh about things
um so I'll just share a couple that are
sort of top of mind there's lots of I
mean that for books on you know sort of
management and actually just general
career books one of my favorites is what
is it called the manager's path by
Camille Fournier and she takes she was
the CTO at Rent the Runway and so she
takes you through how you can think
about your career from as a manager from
you know managing an intern to managing
a few folks managing a larger Team all
the way sort of up up to being an
executive I think that's very useful
both for icus and managers to understand
um
you know how to think about your career
at various levels it's certainly one
that I revisit from time to time you
know as I've moved through my career
um so I found that I find that one to be
super useful
um the high output management book by
Andy Grove is a classic it's one that we
reference a lot that's stripe as well
these again are more management focused
but I think good resources for thinking
about your career
um one that I this uh framework that I
have been using in career conversations
recently is kind of interesting it's
called the scarf framework it's a
neurobiology thing and it's about how
you respond to uh stressful situations
so it's like
uh I'm not sure if I can remember what
what they all are now but it's things
like connectedness autonomy
relationships and thinking about what's
important to you in your work and so I
use that and sort of ask people to talk
about what resonates with them in the
scar framework and it's funny how you
know different people really value
different things when it comes to their
work and what's important to them and so
I'm I found that a very helpful
framework for learning about folks and
for you know folks to sort of
self-identify what's important to them
thank you I was trying to find the link
so it's scarf s-c-a-r-f okay
I like to share some of the links as we
go and the the book that you said by
um
by Andy Grove what was the name of that
one output management high output
management okay
thank you so much Dara for joining us
here it if people do want to get
connected with you or keep in touch as
LinkedIn the best way
yeah it's a bit funny
okay awesome well thank you so much for
for sharing your experience with us and
answering all of our questions thank you
everybody for the great questions as
well thank you Paul great to meet you
all
have a great rest of the day everybody
thank you so much